you
I believe in pink I believe that
laughing is the best calorie burner
I believe in kissing kissing a lot I
believe in being strong when everything
seems to be going wrong
I believe that happy girls are the
prettiest girls I believe that tomorrow
is another day and I believe in miracles
Audrey Hepburn one of the greatest
screen actresses of all time if you want
to achieve success start with what makes
you happy before worrying about what
your one word is think about everything
that makes you happy
start by making a list just write what
comes to mind
and don't worry yet about where it leads
you get lost in happiness as you make
your list here are a few questions to
get you started what's your favorite
movie what's your favorite book what's
your favorite song who is your best
friend what is your favorite quote to
live by what kind of people do you like
to hang out with who is your favorite
bar why are you with your significant
other
who is your favorite teacher what do or
did you love most about your parents
what activities make you come alive what
do you look forward to most in your week
when was the last time you felt
overwhelmingly happy these are all
primers to get you thinking and writing
answer these questions and add whatever
else comes to mind that makes you happy
feel the page that's happiness and feel
the energy that comes from it it could
be the path to your next million dollars
you